okay sorry well thank you very much for
the invitation to speak and one focus of
my group is statistical methods for
analysis of expression data especially
with implications for cancer studies and
so luckily I'm lucky that on monday i
believe it was angela actually spoke
about a alternative splicing and
implications in cancer and that's a nice
biology and introduction for me so i'm
not going to spend a lot of time on that
but just to make sure in case you
weren't there what i'm going to be
speaking about is alternative splicing
and of course what i mean by that is the
process where the pre-mrna can be has
introns that are removed from it and
this can be done in multiple ways that
can result in ultimately different mRNAs
that can therefore then we process into
different proteins for example or it can
be more subtle different mRNAs can have
different likelihoods of being degraded
and have other kinds of effects so don't
always translate directly into proteins
and this process of alternative splicing
has shown up in tantalizing ways in
cancer literature and Angela spoke about
the efforts and her efforts and others
to try to parse out what are these
implications but just to give an example
in AML you have the UTA f1 which is a
splicing factor which is significantly
mutated in lung adenocarcinoma it also
shows up mutations in ssf 3 b1 are very
common even more common than they are
then these are the prevalence is higher
in uveal melanoma and also in CCL and so
these things are showing up and so
there's an interesting question as to
what implications these has splicing has
so what I'm going to talk about is more
our efforts in terms of the methodology
side in terms of statistical applicants
to school analysis of expression data
and what kind of things we can do in in
these types of studies in terms of
methodology development so the first one
links directly to
the type of analysis that Angela spoke
about on Monday and in particular
looking at exons and which exons are
spliced in and out so in just to remind
you of that type of analysis so if we
have mRNA seek data for example from
samples there are different types of
quantities we can be interested in
obviously the most basic one would be
the overall gene expression analysis
which we've been measuring for ages
since microarray data is and earlier
lowest sequencing data of course we can
measure other types of quantities we can
measure we are methods to try to
estimate the individual isoform level
expressions we can also look at
junctions and splicing junctions that
indicate what parts are being spliced in
and out and what we're going to focus on
is is the similar type of analysis that
Angela mentioned where you're really
focused on X done by exxon analysis as
to what is being spliced in and out with
respect to a particular exon and this is
particularly useful in cancer where you
have a lot of novel or you suspect that
you might have novel junctions or novel
types of isoforms or products they're
being created because of the disruption
of the cell so just to be more specific
you know if we have a little cartoon
example we have a set of exons there a
certain number of junctions that will
indicate that the exon was included and
there'll be some junctions that indicate
they were skipped and so we can have
some sort of basic if you like count
matrix where for each X on you have the
number that include in the number that
exclude and what this would of course
generally be summarized by some notion
of the percent spliced and where you
just take this as a percentage and we
want to ask the question are they
different between groups this could be
tumor versus normal but it could also be
one subtype with mutations versus other
samples and so forth and so we're
interesting the question of statistical
methods for how the best and look at
this question so of course their gene
expression has huge amount of
types of methods and the standard sort
of gene analysis framework that we have
coming back from microarray data data is
to look at each individual gene and
separately do some kind of t-test and
then find the significant the Jesus
significant marginal relationships which
is very early on there were huge distal
challenges that were addressed with the
small number of sample size that could
often occur you have large number of
genes and you're making a lot of
estimates so you have problems with
false discovery Corrections and also
instability in your estimates that
mature methods try to account for by
using various types of regularization
and in particular empirical bayes type
strategies and just continuing with the
G an example of course when there was
microarray data you had roughly normal
data sequencing technology gets counts
and so there's a huge industry of
adapting these what we already know
works well in microarray data to count
data so first what's the distribution
you can say it's plus on but that's not
a very adequate model for the data
usually want to add additional
dispersion what's called dispersion
which is like variance the ability to
say that the samples are more variable
than you would see with a plus on and
then questions of shrinkage or a
regularization of your estimates and
there's just a slew of methods that do
this in Gina Gina ray edge our boom Dec
are big ones but there's probably 20 or
30 different proposed methods that
basically do the same strategy in
different ways so just going back to the
exon usage so what we're looking for is
sort of to be able to have a similarly
mature type of analysis for the for this
particular setting and what is different
well we have basically we have two sets
of counts if you like we have the counts
that included in the counts that exclude
or we could rewrite this is the number
that include versus the total and what
we're looking at is the frack fraction
so clearly just from a starting point
plus column doesn't even make sense here
as a starting point it makes much more
sense to think of this is binomial
deezer proportions we're trying to
estimate but we would like to keep the
same kind of strategy and so there's not
so many methods that exist they're
applicable and most of them aren't
not created for Exxon usage either but
for different settings and so we develop
a framework for this over dispersed
binomial data by picking a particular
way to add this dispersion parameter and
then providing a shrinkage estimate and
and as I'll discuss it has some nice
generalizability to other types of
settings beyond just the Exxon usage
which we think is also nice because
there's other alternative splicing
questions that might come up and imply
different settings and so it gives us a
way to expand into other settings
quickly without have to reinvent the
wheel every time so what do I need by an
empirical bayes strategy just to make
that clear well we could start if we
have some data again on our setting if
we were using for example Bayesian
estimates we would say well our data has
some distribution if we know the
parameter and we're going to assume the
Bayesian at the side of it would assume
that parameter actually itself comes
from a distribution it's random and we
would estimate that parameter is the
posterior just posterior mean of the
data and bayesian estimates has some
nice properties that they have this sort
of regularization property that they
that they stabilize their estimates if
you like and they sort of shrink it
towards your prior and moreover this
shrinkage is implicitly controlled by
the method there's no tuning parameter
it's controlled by your sample size so
with larger sample size you shrink less
towards your prior but of course you
have to pick your prior which is an
arbitrary process but we so empirical
based strategy is trying to merge this
Bayesian method with using the data for
the prior estimations so specifically if
I'm thinking I'm doing this same
modeling on thousands of genes I'm not
going to set up a different Bayesian
model for every gene I'm going to use
the same Bayesian model and I'm going to
just repeat thousands of times and so
that what that means is that i'm
assuming i have the same prior for every
every parameter so it may be and ran
it's different for today for every gene
but it's coming from some overall
distribution they can't be that
different from each other there's some
restriction and they share something
about them and so given that i'm doing
this thousands of times I
able to look at my data and say
something about that not just have to
take it arbitrarily and that's the idea
of empirical bayes is that I've done
this so many times that if I can look at
the marginal distribution integrate out
the the parameter and look at the
marginal then I have a lot of
information about my prior which I can
think about is the parameter alpha and
once I know that prior then I can then
calculate with this data prior what my
estimate would be and so you get the
shrinkage towards the data now the
overall bulk of the data across exons
and jeans and so this is like a
likelihood method for shrinkage and
again doesn't require any tuning
parameters in general this is actually
difficult to do what I just described
exactly the way I described it in
particular if you don't have nice
distributions that play nicely with each
other these processes can be difficult
so in particular we have multiple
parameters going around not just one and
so we want to have different treatments
of say the mean versus the variability
and then also depending on what
distributions I'm picking it's not
always easy to work with priors and
create empirical based strategies in
particular a negative binomial which is
what's used in the gene world this is a
this is a big hurdle and so there's a
lot of other sort of pseudo strategies
that try to get at doing this basic idea
so in printing and so what we do is we
pick a particular choice of a dispersion
model so a particular way to describe to
take an initial model like a plus on or
binomial add dispersion to it so that
you have this variability that you need
to capture population dynamics and and
this is a method proposed for Efron and
its general which is nice compared to
some of the other strategies that are
usually used it can be used for a normal
binomial prasanna multinomial anything
in the exponential family and so what we
show is that in fact if you look at the
maximum likelihood estimate its
approximately gamma distributed and more
so by doing this we can develop an
empirical based strategy so that we can
then use conjugate priors and go forward
and actually get an analytic solution
for how we would shrink our data or
regularize our estimates with respect to
the rest of the data and
and so this is we focus we can use this
for again any distribution but again we
focus on the binomial because we're
interested in the X on usage case where
we're looking at proportions and justice
give some idea there are a few other
methods not so many I can put them all
on one plot as opposed to gene estimates
and so looking at simulated data are
it's striking that most of the other
methods do not control the false
discovery rate so in particular you can
have you know you can have a reported
falsity of ten percent and actually
you're getting somewhere around the
order of forty percent false discovery
rate so sometimes it can be really quite
large what the difference between them
and this is not actually simulated under
our model this is simulated under their
models and we also have relatively high
power that in terms of the rank of the
discoveries we find tend to be we have
to go pretty far down our list
relatively before we start finding false
ranks compared to other techniques and
we can also so then we also look on real
data sorry oh I'm sorry that's an
important part I'm sorry I forgot about
that my method is the black line here
the web seeks so the one that follows
sorry so the black line the one that
gives you a low false discovery rate and
gives you a relatively low ranking of
when you find your first boss yes and
the other one that has sort of some
high-power just has very very high rates
of false discovery so so they can find
some things but you don't have any
confidence confidence in it
oh so I didn't talk about that but then
I go back in and I use these dispersion
estimates and now I test between the
groups between the means using
likelihood ratio statistics based on the
model and it's it's just a it's sort of
the same thing it's like a ratio so it's
not gonna be so different but yeah
that's what we use as a standard yes we
looked at different tests and and they
do have impact on how well they perform
sorry and so again looking at a more
realistic setting where we actually
create a null setting so there isn't any
truth in there by randomly just
permuting real data and we find similar
behavior in terms of the fact that most
methods have very high for false
discovery rate although I'm sorry this
is false positive rates because we don't
have false discovery rates in the study
and and then if we look here we're
actually comparing different we are
trying to make sure that there was
something to find so we're actually
comparing two different tumors from
different tissue types so we're largely
not picking up a tumor signal but
picking up a tissue sample which we know
will be large and we find that in
general most of the things we find are
supported by other methods but most of
the other methods find a large large
number of things they're just not
supported by any other method and here I
only short for but we actually compared
to like eight different methods and even
when you compare across all the eight
methods most of them are just finding
things novel to their method even though
they're assuming the same distribution
and the same things unlike us so it's so
it gives it a Malaysian that what the
things we're finding seem to be reliable
so the other thing i didn't mention is
that you can also use the same kind of
analysis looking at exons by using
isoform counts and so that's that's the
same idea and as i mentioned it extends
to other distributions easily so for
example if you start with a Poisson
instead of binomial could do gene
expression and we don't really want to
get into the gene expression fight
because there's about I've showed the
only a handful of the many things out
there there's a lot of methods for gene
expression but just as a point and
principle that it expands well we again
control the false discovery rate pretty
well even though this isn't our
distribution and we have pretty high
rankings in terms of the things we find
more interesting is that you can then
expand into other settings for example
you could look at the multinomial and
try to be comparing isoform proportions
rather than just / exxon and things like
this and it gives us straight forward
nothing changes everything stays the
same regardless of the distribution okay
and so then the other area that we've
been looking at is something that's
particularly relevant for tumor settings
is actually novel subtype rather than
starting with groups that you want to
compare trying to find clustering and
how does alternative splicing impact or
influence that process so in general
when we're clustering people we have
isoform estimates from mrna see data but
we're still largely I think using gene
expressions and for example in many of
the TCGA papers and that that's probably
not a generally a very big problem we
would think impacted many genes if you
look for example across individuals and
at the gene expression and if you then
broke it into the isoforms in that gene
you would have many genes that might
look like this there's not really a
large pattern difference of how they're
performing however we do know that there
are some genes that these genes exist
that do have isoform differences so for
example we can look at a different gene
and we look at their isoforms and we can
see that in a subset of samples there is
a real switching behavior as to which
isoforms they're using relative to the
other to the other samples and this
doesn't show up from a clustering you
know if you're trying to find them in
the gene it's it you might find it but
it's not a very strong signal here
compared to what is a very striking
signal here over in the isoform
estimation if we look more broadly in
across many isoforms if we look for
example in the TCGA FML data we look at
the subset of variable isoforms and then
we take those same genes that they came
from and just look at their gene
expression estimates some of them don't
change right like this blue group
doesn't look so very different here the
in a gene expression versus the isoform
but there are some groups here
that has strikingly different patterns
when you go from one to the other we're
missing some signal when we make that
transformation into a gene into the gene
world and similarly if we look at the
UVM data we can find similar types of
patterns where again a lot of it stays
the same but we have again it just
happens to be colored the same it's not
the same group by any means but we have
a diminution in the signal here and in
fact we have the set of samples it seems
to look very different here in a way
that they did it in the isoform and in
fact when you cluster the gene
clustering picks up these samples in a
way that the isoform clustering does not
clearly when we're talking about
clustering it's a numbers game because
clustering is driven by these large
group and we have thousands of genes
it's driven by these large groups of co
expressing genes in book and so what
effect is going to have is not clear
because you can be missing the signal on
a lot of genes and still manage to
cluster perfectly well because there's
so many other genes perhaps with the
same signal right so it's a kind of
question mark as to how important it is
so for example if we so we sort of look
first just to see what kind of
differences do you see the AML paper
oops sorry mom button the AML paper when
they find their clusters they look at
spliceosome for example and they don't
find any particular noticeable patterns
when we look at the same data we look at
specific genes and we do seem to see
more patterns in the sense that the UTA
vf1 if we accumulate all different kinds
of mutations and copy number changes do
seem to cluster well as though these but
we'd also note that we find those same
patterns pretty much in the gene and
they could very well be related to just
the fact that these are also samples
that have complex rearrangements and
there could be other things that are
driving it that we're picking up as well
and I would also note that the pay this
is different than the paper we're not
able we're not recapitulating the
results of the paper so that's also a
caveat although they make biological
sense on other respects and similarly if
we look at the UVM data and we oh I'm
sorry I meant to say one more thing is
that so they're generally pretty much
the same although it is interesting
that you have one particular fusion gene
that is clustering into two different
groups depending on how you cluster it
so it is making an impact and similarly
if you look at the UVM data where they
have a fairly highly prevalent mutation
and a splicing factor you seem like you
probably are getting a little bit more
clustering of that splicing factor into
two groups not the same groups but two
different groups versus the middle
compared to the gene so at least
suggests a question but there might be
some kind of overriding splicing
patterns that could be detected by
looking at the isoform so then the last
thing I talked about is some ideas we
have been working on on trying to really
look at clustering from this point of
view what is their shared in terms of
splicing in particular and so what do we
mean by this world war the way we've
been thinking about this is rather than
clustering isoforms and just throwing
them into a clustering technique on
their own can we put them in as a group
so to speak and cluster on them based on
their group behavior in other words how
they perform relative to the other
isoforms so rather than just taking
these two isoforms clustering and
separately do we get some advantage by
looking at them as a group and their
relative performance in particular we
could look for example this proportion
and we could convert these into
proportions and we would have one number
that's a proportion and we could use
that instead now obviously we actually
tend to have more than just two isoforms
and many of these genes and so we can
look at other isoform expressions and
but we can still look at the relative
proportion and try to use this as sort
of a proxy as to how its performing
relatives to the other Sam um samples
and see if we can get different types of
signals when we cluster on them so what
do I mean specifically I'm going to do
well for each rather than having say
genes by sample which is the standard
data input what I'm going to have is
jeans by samples and then another
dimension on my ray only it's going to
be a ragged array because I'm not going
to have the same dimension for different
rows because isoforms will have
different numbers of dips our genes will
have different numbers of isoforms so it
won't be the same set that's not a very
attractive input for most clustering
algorithms so we that was a strategy we
take to try to
on this clustering is to think about
each gene separately in particular for
each what does a clustering algorithm
really usually wind up being is some
kind of distance between samples and so
instead of trying to tackle this thing
directly instead what we take is we look
at each gene and creating a distance
matrix for each gene is not difficult
and there's a lot of ways of comparing
distances for vectors that are on a
simplex for example you can a entropy
distance Hellinger there's all these
different things and we can get a
different distance for each gene and
then try to combine them so standard
clustering algorithms basically do this
anyways and they just take the average
you could imagine using a weighted
average and and we have tried that and
not had a whole lot of and you could
imagine trying to find the best weights
from the data but we haven't had a lot
of luck and we get very a variable and
unstable results so we haven't really
pursued that any further so the question
could be is what more do you get out of
grouping them together versus treating
them separately because implicitly all
that information should be in the
isoform so why not just cluster the
isoform shouldn't you be able to get it
back so the first thing that was the
first thing we were asking when we look
at simulated data at least which I don't
you know you don't want to push too far
but at least it gives you an idea that
there is some information or additional
sensitivity you get by grouping them so
in particular if we look at the
similarity to the truth we have the
isoform method here and we have methods
that work by grouping the dice of forms
into jeans and we can see that we get
you know improved performance on the
simulated data so at least in principle
you can find things that you might not
be able to find as well if you were
looking in the clustering data so we
look and we look for example in the the
work on that Angela presented in in
finding differences and if we just
isolate ourselves to the set of genes
that they find have significant
differences we are able to recapitulate
the cluster it's not the first break but
it's pretty close to two there another
thing that we can do is if we look at
the AML data we can just try to apply
this to all the email data so the first
our first round of doing this was a
success in a certain this sense we very
successfully identified a batch of it
and we identified it really precisely in
the sense that if you these are
different clustering techniques this is
the gene isoform and the proportion and
this is the plates in which the AML were
were on and so we almost perfectly
recapitulated the plate effect using our
proportions the isoform finds it to some
degree but not so nicely and the gene
eventually starts to find it but it's
not so to speak of priority and so does
this have anything to do with
alternative splicing well maybe in fact
if you look at this five prime to three
prime coverage that suspect plate that
looks very different from the others
which could really affect your isoform
estimation procedures if you have a
different kind of coverage over them
this was not found this was not
reporting the AML but we have some
question marks because I think they did
some kind of batch correction so that's
a gold standard of a sort it's not very
interesting but at least it seems to
work on large scales in that setting so
then we were interested in doing after
we normalize the AML data except for
this one slide everything else I
demonstrate it was on normal I corrected
batch corrected data so if we look at
the batch corrected data what kind of
information can we find we can find that
we do get some different clusterings
from the proportions in particular this
is the cluster identification of the
samples and these are the different
isoforms across the rows and we can see
that they are highlighting two different
things in particular if i look at the
proportions they seem to be matching
much more these sets of cluster these
sets of isoforms compared to for example
some of these other isoforms that
perhaps match more with the isoform
clustering again it's a numbers game
it's kind of where is the focus going to
be in the clustering well so what kind
of thing is happening here when we find
when we look at some of the genes that
we see there there's a strong switching
pattern where there will be one isoform
that's in say the green group another
one that's in the blue group and we can
see that there's a strong switching
pattern
that is creating different clusters and
it and it seems to be shared in this
behavior in particular what does that
mean more more generally well how does
this look like when you look across the
genome so in press the transcriptome in
particular if we look at this blue
cluster which doesn't match our
clustering a lot of their genes sort of
match that a description i showed before
a lot of their isoforms match the
description i show before that there's
not a lot of difference across the gene
in fact if i look at the isoforms that
are in this blue cluster and i see how
many of the other isoforms that are in
its gene or also in the blue cluster
it's also it's about seventy percent so
most of these isoforms all of the
isoforms from that gene are also showing
up in the same cluster so it makes sense
that they all have the same expression
pattern and that's not something that's
interesting to the proportion but if
instead I look at the green and this
sian color we see this switching pattern
I showed before and in fact they are
co-occurring at sort of significant
rates much they're much more crossing in
the sense that the gene will have one
isoform in one group and the other
isoform in another group and that's what
we're picking up from the proportion
clustering and so in general it seems
like there may be widespread splicing
patterns I want to go so far to say they
are but there are at least looking at
isoforms and looking at the mutations it
does seem to be that there is some
possible signal there and a more
widespread nature and that we think by
clustering on isoforms as a group in a
gene for example by taking their
proportions or in other ways can sort of
give it a refined will look in terms of
the priority you given your clustering
between the isoform and the expression
patterns and just to acknowledge my
student son ready who worked on the
first part about different to exon
analysis and Marla who's been working on
the clustering and the data from the
Cancer Genome Atlas thank you
thank you do you have a question oh okay
yes survival and any of the new clusters
that you see um we haven't we haven't
gone down that I would be surprised
frankly if there was but I mean I that
would I would be say I feel like it's a
P it was it's a piece but I don't know I
i we we it's something we've been
meaning to do and I think we looked at
it briefly but I couldn't say what the
results are so I'll just say we haven't
done it I think I suspect we've looked
at in and it wasn't particularly
interesting but i'll bet different
methods for alternative splicing
performance of coverage is very do they
have oh sorry I thought you're gonna ask
me a different question a more
downstream question why I was going to
say that I had we initially started by
making our own isoform estimates and
then we switched over to TCGA estimates
and we see a similar behavior and
they're two different algorithms and run
from oh I'm sorry what are you talking
about first part try to predict
alternate oh oh I'm sorry oh ok I
thought your talk about the batch effect
with the coverage so you're saying how
does the different different different
methods for determining alternative
splicing do they perform differently in
different coverage regimes so are there
perhaps methods that are much better at
low coverage just high coverage because
there's different ways you could use the
signal ok so you're talking about like
basically the overall count level
there's dead the depth oh I'm sorry I
thought you meant how it was distributed
across the gene that's why I was going
to the batch um well I would think that
probably as you get high coverage some
of these questions become a lot less
important right as soon as you're well
so one thing I would say is they for
example if you're looking at the
splicing junctions you have much much
lower counts than you would looking a
gene or isoform or anything else so
you're in a very very low count level
compared to two
counts as well right so 50s sound short
or long and yeah so that depends which
way you do you can do it both ways you
could include the exon counts or not and
if you include the exon counseling you
get a much higher I'm coverage but some
people aren't super comfortable with
doing that and prefer to look at just
the Junction's I think we've done in
both ways and I think actually what I'm
showing here includes the exon count
sexually but having said that so I think
that there's a longer way to go four
exons to get to high depths but at some
point when you get to high depth a lot
of the nuances about we need to use
account distribution and be careful
about it and so forth makes a lot less
difference in particular you know if
we're just our my gene expression if you
have very very high counts taking along
and doing standard microwave stuff will
be probably okay it's the low count
regimes or when you have low count in
one side or another that matters so but
for the exon I think you're much much
you're so far away from the gene thing
the gene level of counts that I think
that you would have to have a
significant bump up to not have that
influence in terms of the different
count methods
I I don't think that we've played that
but I don't think we saw any
relationship between the overall I like
which ones we were finding false or
positive related to the overall count so
that's one of the closest I don't think
we explicitly like downsampled
everything or upsampled everything but
in terms of looking at the exons we had
which had a pretty large range of
coverage I don't think we saw any bias
there with respect to that
so I mean the main mutations we were
looking at war ones in the spliceosome
which were the ones that i was showing
in the pictures but you know if you look
trying to see if i have a picture of any
of them but i mean so we have other
features the mutations when we were for
example when we're looking at ml we
tended to focus on the ones that from
the AML paper and other things I mean
it's very well characterized and so we
tended to focus on those which in AML
includes a lot of fusions for example
and some deletions and amplifications
and I guess this is a mutation here so
that was our focus but in that sense yes
we did we did look at that in
interestingly the particular spliced
mutations and there's only seven of them
it looks like there's a lot but most of
these are copy number amplifications or
deletions but there's only I think six
or seven samples that had the mutation
and so while when we looked at the
specific set of genes that a priori
should show the difference then we get a
clustering of those particular splicing
but when we look over all looking at the
proportions is not improving the
splicing of those particular mutations
I had to be honest I'm not sure that we
looked over all possible mutations I
think we looked at the mutations that
were found significant and from that
from the paper output
can be
I would think it would certainly be the
key it certainly could be the case I
don't personally know a lot of knowledge
about the diversity of isoforms within a
tumor I they may exist i've not seen a
lot of work of that i would think it
would make a difference yes it would be
without but it's hard to know exactly in
in what way but I would to certainly
think so I'm sorry I look for mutations
in the I didn't hear well that's true
yeah and you could look and see and try
to parse them back with the isoform yeah
if you're lucky if you're if you're
lucky you might get some information but
I think it would be pretty sparse as to
how many genes that would give you very
much information about okay
you